joël d'allègre bonjour m'intègre alors
vous êtes historien de maîtresse de
conférences à l'inalco et spécialiste de
la grèce moderne merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors on le voit une réforme des
retraites qui provoquent beaucoup de
manifestations à athènes mais également
ailleurs on sait que la grèce a déjà
réformé ses retraite en 2016 c'était
sous le gouvernement s'y pressent à
l'époque puisque le fmi l'union
européenne l'avait exigé pour faire face
à la crise financière pourquoi
aujourd'hui le gouvernement conservateur
qui est au pouvoir veut de nouveau
réformer cette retraite depuis 2008 tous
les gouvernements quelle que soit leur
couleur ou réformés ont touché aux
retraites on doit en être à peu près à
la 10e au 10e texte sur le sujet et
c'est vrai que l'europe le demande au
nom des économies et maintenant s'y
ajouter le fait que aucun gouvernement
ne sait comment finalement dans 20 ou 30
ans il pourrait payer les retraites
donc ça fait un deuxième argument et les
réformes vont toutes dans le même sens
petits morceaux par petits morceaux
c'est reculer l'âge donc maintenant
c'est 65 67 ans et diminuer les
retraites c'est ce qui dérange le plus
les grecs le dès l'âge de départ à la
retraite je pense qu'il ya eu également
une baisse des pensions à la fin ah oui
c'est surtout la baisse des pensions je
veux dire entre 2010 et 2015 selon
selon la somme de faim qu'on touchait
les gens ont perdu entre 20 et 50 %
quand même au dessus de 2000 euros par
mois ils ont perdu en cinq ans 50% de
retraite ce qui quand même quelque chose
et là la réforme en cours
ce n'est plus officiellement une
diminution des retraites c'est une
augmentation des cotisations de santé
donc de facto il restera moins pour le
la personne et un nouveau mode de calcul
qui fait qu'avec ce nouveau mode de
calcul les gens vont toucher entre 20 et
30% de moins cela demande à un nouvel
effort à la population y est pourtant
ils ont fait beaucoup d'efforts depuis
la crise financière est ce que il peut
survivre à ça le peuple grec mais à
l'heure actuelle il ya quand même
presque la moitié des retraités qui
touchent moins que le seuil de pauvreté
officiellement défini par le
gouvernement et les retraités souvent
contribuer je dirais à l'ensemble de la
vie familiale puisque c'est encore le
pays où il ya le plus de chômeurs en
europe et que les chômeurs grec
pratiquement bout de six mois ne touche
absolument plus rien donc en fait c'est
la solidarité familiale qui vient en
aide aux plus jeunes donc la diminution
des retraites ça ne touche pas que celui
qui touche sa retraite ça affecte toute
la famille donc ça me nourrit toutes les
troupes de le concerner est ce qu'il ya
des similitudes entre le projet grec et
le projet français voilà ce que
on peut essayer de faire un parallèle
entre les deux oui oui surtout la
dernière version je veux dire augmenter
les cotisations pour ne pas baisser la
retraite augmenter les cotisations
changer le système de calcul de la
retraite donc on vous dit pas on va
blesser la retraite dans vous dis
simplement on va changer le système de
calcul et comme par hasard ces systèmes
de calcul fait que vous toucherez mois
bon en même temps c'est vrai que la
grèce est en train de devenir le pays le
plus vieux d'europe
on y vit aussi veut qu'en france mais
par contre il n'y a plus d'enfants
je veux dire depuis 2010 il ya beaucoup
plus de morts que de naissances chaque
année ça s'aggrave et depuis 2010 aussi
il ya près de cinq cent mille personnes
qui sont parties sur un peu plus de 10
millions d'habitants et ses cinq cent
mille personnes sont toutes des jeunes
donc effectivement du même coup c'est
pas ça qui va augmenter si j'ose dire
les éventuels de natalité et les gens
vous disent très gentiment que dans un
pays où les ressources sont si maigres
et où l'avenir et si noir faire des
enfants n'est pas une bonne idée
en france
la population et puis les syndicats on
le voit dans tous les corps de métier en
général se sont mobilisés pour demander
le retrait de la réforme des retraites
en grèce aussi commencent à se mobiliser
c'est la première mobilisation je crois
la première manifestation d'autres
d'autres mouvements sont à venir et ce
qui est une possibilité pour le
gouvernement de retirer tout simplement
ce projet où est-ce qu'ils vont aller
jusqu'au bout je pense qu'il ira
jusqu'au bout parce que en cette île
nous tant que l'union européenne ne
change pas les exigences financières sur
les éventuels excédents du budget et
cetera qu'il doit présenter il a pas
beaucoup d'autres solutions
et en plus les grecs reçoit regard
beaucoup la france donc je dis ça fait
deux mois qu'ils voient bien que
finalement chez nous ce n'est pas d'une
efficacité extraordinaire donc
donc on peut s'attendre à encore
beaucoup d'agitation en grèce autour de
cette réforme des retraites
et oui très bien en tout cas merci
beaucoup
joël de la glotte d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historiés de maîtresse de conférences à
l'inalco et spécialiste de la grèce
moderne
merci